hello i'm christopher manning and today
i want to discuss the game-changing
impact of large pre-trained language
models in natural language processing
ranging from their linguistic
implications to how the approach seems
likely to transform machine learning and
ai more generally
starting from the viewpoint of human
language my topic today plays out some
of the more recent episodes of a drama
series that's actually been running for
70 years since i'm from before i was
born in the 1950s
for higher level language acquisition
and understanding the most dominant
voice of the 20th century was noam
chomsky who has argued against the idea
of probabilistic models of language or
the idea that languages can be learned
from the evidence available to children
among other quotes in 1969 he said but
it must be recognized that the notion of
probability of a sentence is an entirely
useless one
under any known interpretation of this
term
this stands in contrast to the approach
of claude shannon the pioneer of
information theory who outlined many of
the statistical information theory tools
that we now standardly use to think
about human communication in
computational linguistics and in 1951 he
said anyone speaking a language
possesses implicitly an enormous
knowledge of the statistics of the
language enabling them to complete an
unfinished phrase
central to the rise of probabilistic
models of language was the concept of a
language model
so a language model is a formal
mathematical model that predicts words
in the context so if i have a context
like the students open there we would
like to be able to say that words likely
to come next are words such as books
laptops exams or minds and to have a
language model what we're then doing is
placing a probability distribution over
what this next word will be by assigning
probabilities to all the different
possible words that could occur
language models are a key part of speech
and natural language processing they are
used everywhere in decoding tasks like
speech recognition and spelling
correction and in any language
generation tasks including machine
translation summarization and story
generation
traditionally in the 20th century
language models were built by counting
how often word sequences occurred and
dividing to get conditional
probabilities so you could literally
take a large amount of speech or text
and count how often the students opened
their books occurred say 11 times find
out how often the students open there
occurred say 187 times and divide
through
to get a probability of 0.06
the first problem here was this is a
classic cursive dimensionality scenario
that as you condition on more words of
context the number of parameters that
your model has goes up exponentially and
so these models commonly
needed even in small models millions and
larger models billions of parameters the
second problem is that with so many
contexts and words to be estimated the
estimates become very noisy because the
counts are sparse so over here i've got
a little
probably smooth somehow
graph from
google engrams of how often the students
open their books occurred over the
decades and as you can see there are
years where it didn't occur at all and
then occasionally there are appearances
so something had to be done to improve
these probability estimates and the
techniques that were used were things
like a markov assumption of simply using
a shorter context so estimating the next
word maybe just based on the two
previous words um books based on open
there or more complex techniques of
discounting and smoothing the
probability distributions using mixture
or back off models etc
um but despite the crudeness of these
models the funny thing is that even a
very simple one sort of works and was
useful this was the mainstay of what we
use for speech recognition and machine
translation in the 90s and 2000s decade
so if you have a unigram model well then
you're just using the
relative frequency of words so you get
english words coming out but there's
sort of no sentence structure
at all but once you have a bigram model
white dust stand fourth thigh canopy
these models were trained off
shakespeare or a trigram model fly and
will rid me these news of price we're
starting to have something that already
starts to capture something that almost
looks like english text it doesn't
really make sense but it starts to
almost look like english text already
and that improves as you go on to
foreground and five gram models
so
um human language communication happens
via sequences of words but language
understanding requires constructing rich
hierarchical structures using the
grammar of a language or its syntax that
are never observed explicitly and so the
question is how much of that intricate
structure of human language do these
language models know
in the 90s and 2000s
the answer of linguists often
passionately argued was almost none
engram models do know quite a bit of
simple world knowledge so that they know
that ships are sailed and sync and are
anchored
and
in an aggregated way they know some
low-level syntax so
they know at an instance level that you
tend to get um sequences like
preposition article noun or article
adjective noun they just know that in
their accounts
but the linguists argued that they don't
have any generalization they don't have
the concept of a noun or any of the
center structure rules of an abstracted
grammar as human beings do
and as a result of that not only in
linguistics but also natural language
processing the whole direction in the
90s and the 2000s decades was to believe
that what we needed to do was build
models that knew about
the deeper structure of human languages
for both their grammar their syntax and
their semantics and the way that that
was then approached was as a supervised
machine learning problem so what we had
to do was produce supervised training
data labeled data that showed the
structures that we wanted models to
learn and that led to the construction
of a lot of resources such as tree banks
here i'm showing a pen tree bank
sentence sewing grammatical structure
but also label data sets for lots of
other things such as sentiment analysis
named entity recognition co-reference
resolution and so on
but meanwhile during the same period
they started to develop an alternative
and people um famously beginning with um
joshua benjio and colleagues work around
the turn of the millennium started
exploring the idea of using neural
networks for building language models
and these neural language models had
some very promising properties the first
is that they could solve the cursive
dimensionality of needing billions of
parameters so rather than having words
as symbols they represented words as
real vectors so you'd have something
like a 300 dimensional vector that
represented a word and the reason that
helps is then because you can have
sharing of statistical strength via the
vector component so a bunch of words
that means something similar like hotel
and motel and in will have similarity
in some of the dimensions of their
vector representation and that will
allow a sharing of predictive power for
the probabilities
um
that much you got from just the kind of
simple feedforward neural networks that
benjard l used but then in the next
decade people got much further than that
and were also able to
model
the influence of much longer contexts by
means of recurrent neural network models
so
using a few words to predict as either
the engram models did or the first
neural models has some limitations let
us look at this example from an arthur
miller short story if i just tell you
the prior context is he refused to have
maybe you'd guess an operation
um a party um
even if i'd given you more context and
said in the past
30 years in which he refused to have
you'd still not really have much idea of
what word should come
next in this particular
story extract you really have to look
all the way back to the stump the same
stump which had impaled the car of many
a guest in the past 30 years and which
you refused to have to make it obvious
that the word that comes next is removed
and this
kind of long context you can capture by
our current neural network without
having an exponential increase in the
number of parameters
i'll explain that in a minute but first
let me just say a bit more about these
word vectors these word vectors are
trained in an unsupervised way by taking
a lot of text and setting the vector
components
using an iterative learning algorithm so
that words are better able to predict
the occurrence of other words in their
context with that very simple
self-supervised learning mechanism we
get these word vector representations
which we can think of as a high
dimensional vector space it's hard to
show you a high dimensional vector space
all i can do is project two dimensions
of that but even with that we can see
the interesting structure learned in
this space not yet in this picture but
if we start to zoom into parts of the
space so as legible here's a part of the
space um where countries are appearing
so we have country names over here and
then the adjectival forms australian
american european over here if we skip
to a different part of the space here we
can see verbs and not only oops not only
have we got a whole bunch of verbs here
i mean there's a lot of structure even
within this space so over here we have
um auxiliary verbs so here's the verb to
be and here's the forms of have
other what is sometimes called copula
verbs that um i like the verb to be um
you know john is a doctor as close to
john became a doctor the camp become and
remain a close to be
over here we have um verbs and mental
states say think expect that there's a
lot of structure learned in these spaces
okay so this is how our current neural
language model works so we start off
with the words and then we look up the
vector encoding of those words the word
embedding and then the recurrent neural
network
calculates hidden states to represent
the past context and the way it does
that is it takes
the previous hidden state
the new words word vector and calculates
a new hidden state using the equation
over here and it can chug along and chug
along and then to predict what word is
going to come next from this hidden
state it is then using a softmax
regression style equation
to put a probability distribution over
following words
this was a very powerful tool but in
this tool lay the seeds of an even more
powerful tool because in the last few
years what people noticed is actually
there's a different way that we could
think about these hidden states when we
have a hidden state like this one we
could think of it as actually being a
context-specific
representation of the word opened that
you can think of this as representing
the meaning and grammatical
possibilities of the word opened in the
context of the students preceding it and
as that idea that has gone on to
revolutionize what has happened in nlp
in the last few years
so starting just in 2018 so three years
ago people started to build on that idea
and to think if we
trained very large language models we
could then use them as context-specific
representations of words and that would
give us a way to improve natural
language understanding in general so it
started in 2018 with elmo and olmfit
but
it quickly then took off and part of
what allowed it to take off was the
development of a new neural model the
transformer model which was much more
parallelizable and like recurrent neural
networks which were kind of inherently
sequential in calculating successive
states and so with these models we saw
an enormous growth in model size so we
moved from having models that were being
trained on about 100 million words to
models trained on a billion words a few
billion words 40 billion words heading
up and the other thing to notice is that
at the same time
the
size of the compute needed to train
these models was also exploding from one
gpu day to 240 gpu days um to now that
these large models this training time is
being measured in gpu or more commonly
tpu years
but their success has been astounding so
most directly a language model is giving
you a way to generate text and if we
look at a model like openai's gpt2 what
we find is that it then generates just
exceedingly good text compared to the
language models that i showed you
earlier so if we give it an initial
prompt a train carriage containing
controlled nuclear materials was stolen
in cincinnati today its whereabouts are
unknown then using that context gpt-2
can generate things like the incident
occurred on the downtown train line
which runs from covington and national
and stations in an email to ohio news
outlets the us department of energy said
it is working with the federal railroad
administration to find the thief the
theft of this nuclear material will have
significant negative consequences on
public and environmental health our
workforce and the economy of our nation
said tom hicks the us energy secretary
dot dot dot and so what we see is that
for what's generated here not only is it
grammatically and
semantically impeccable it looks just
like text that you might read in a
newspaper but it also makes sense as a
longer discourse so it is picked up in
all the material that was in the prompt
so it knows there's a train carriage so
it starts talking about a downline
downtown train line and the federal
railroad administration oops
there's mention of controlled nuclear
materials so it talks about
the us department of energy
which it knows
regulates nuclear materials in the
united states stolen in cincinnati
mentioned of ohio news outlets a thief
some material stolen so it mentions a
thief it's all makes
discourse sense as something that fits
together
but these models weren't only useful for
generating text so it introduced a new
model of building natural language
processing systems
and this was most famously demonstrated
with the burt model done at google so
first of all what you did was
pre-trained a large language model on
billions of words of text
and then
for any particular task you wanted to do
perhaps question answering sentiment
analysis named entity recognition
you would then take a small amount of
supervised data
for that task place a simple softmax
classifier on top of your squad model
sorry on top of your bert model and then
you could fine-tune your large
transformer model on a little bit of
supervised data and it would perform
extremely well for doing that different
natural language processing tasks
i'm not going to go through all the
details of transformer models there's
actually quite a lot of moving parts and
they're quite complex but the most
central idea that they introduced was an
idea of multi-headed attention so let me
just quickly mention that because we'll
need that later so
in the burt model what you're doing is
predicting
mass words in a context that's a
double-sided context and one of the
central results of bert is using that
double-sided context could actually be
very effective
for inducing word representations and
models compared to the single-sided
context of a traditional language model
or gpt too
so these you start for each position
with a word representation that comes
from a word vector in its position in
the sentence but what you do next in
cheap invert is you using linear
projection vectors you calculate from
each hidden representation
query key and value vectors and then
using the query at a certain position
you compare it simply with the dot
product to the keys at every position in
the sentence and so that gives you a
kind of similarity to between the queen
the query and the key at each position
and based on those similarity scores you
calculate a weighted average of the of
the values and you send those up to the
next layer then the second major
innovation of these transformer models
block beyond using attention was to use
a lot of attention so you don't do that
just once you have a whole bunch of
queries keys and values projected from
each hidden state say 12 and you
calculate a new representation the same
way for each of them which we then
assemble together into the hidden
representation at the next layer and you
don't just stop there you then proceed
upward doing layers of this calculation
new representations
based on the context using attention
but the success was indisputable so if
we take a task such as question
answering the well-known squad um
benchmark for my colleague percy liang
at stanford in this you are given a
passage and a question and your goal is
to read the passage and answer it so
which team won super bowl 50 in this
passage it's the denver broncos
this was a task that
started off with traditional symbolic
feature-based machine learning nlp
models which would get about 51 percent
people quickly started using um deep
learning models already using simple
attention and that got you into the 70s
including up into the high 70s with my
former student chen's doctor qa model in
2017
but still massively
below the
measured performance mechanical turk
workers and 91 percent
once
models like burt were discovered though
you couldn't get onto this leaderboard
unless you started using bert so in
early 2019 all the best systems um were
using bert and the performance now was
in the mid to high
80s
two years later with bigger transformer
models
the measured system performance is now
above
this
mechanical turkish performance so i
think we have to differentiate between
mechanical
turkas
working fast and the true limits of
human performance
and that there were just many other uses
among other things um google used the
burt architecture model in web search
where they describe it as the single
innovation to produce the greatest gains
since the initial introduction of
pagerank
now a couple of decades ago
okay so in the rest of this talk what i
want to do is first tell you a bit about
two pieces of work um
students and i have been involved in
related to these large transformer
language models and then conclude with a
few thoughts about where things will go
from here
this first piece of work gets us back to
where i started with shannon and chomsky
and the question of
how
to what extent
language models can be started to be
thinking
but the extent to which language models
can be thought of as models that know
about the structure of human languages
so does a bert model start to know more
about the structure of human languages
than an engram language model well we
can start to interrogate that an easy
way to interrogate it is to say that for
each of these many attention heads for
each word position we can look at where
bert is paying attention
in particular we can look at the most
attended two word for each head and we
might wonder whether bert is sensitive
to linguistic and
structure in terms of where it looks
so if we do that and we start looking at
the lowest levels of alberta
architecture that they do fairly simple
things so there are some heads that
attend broadly we might call them bag of
words heads to look at every word in the
context and then there's some
heads that look at the preceding word or
look at the next word
but given that your representation of
the position of a word has no idea of
the context around it these are actually
the obvious and most sensible things to
do because just generally knowing what
the sentence is about with the bag of
words head that's useful and if you want
to learn about your context and you can
only look at one thing clearly the
immediately adjacent words and the most
useful ones to look at that's why we
built bigram models all those decades
ago
but if we look at the higher levels of
the model then we start to
notice some really interesting things so
we might wonder if some of these high
level heads actually know about the
syntactic structure of languages so one
syntactic structure that is used as
dependency trees where words point to
the words that they that are their
syntactic dependence and this
representation maps very naturally onto
attention so here we have the verb went
that has two dependents it's subject i
and it's prepositional modifier the
preposition has a prepositional object
dependent which in turn has
a determiner modifying it so we can then
look and see if we see these kind of
syntactic relationships in the models
and we actually do so there are a bunch
of heads that specialize on syntactic
relations
so
that head 10 at level 8 it specializes
on having direct objects pointing to
verbs well actually strictly not just
the direct object but all the words in
the direct object noun phrase so
painweber considered an even harder cell
recommending specific stocks all of an
even harder cell point to considered and
specific stocks point to recommending
head 11 on the same layer has
noun pre-modifiers attending to their
head so the complicated language in the
new law has muddied the fight so that
uncomplicated point to language um in
the huge new all point to law
fine point prepositions also point so
this is like extended projection for
linguists
has muddied the fight that points to
fight
um there's other stuff you can find
going on as well so hit four at the
fifth level actually models co-reference
so with kim today as she got some expert
opinions on the damage to her home we
find that um kim
she and her all co-referent in this
sentence and all of them are then
pointing to each other with um head
four and level five it's not only for um
pronouns um heading back to their
referent nouns it also happens with
other co referent nouns so joining peace
talks between israel and the
palestinians the negotiations are you
have negotiations and talks pointing
between each other
um that's a good start but we might even
wonder if there's a little bit more
structure than that can we actually
think of a bert representation of
learning the entire syntactic structure
of a sentence
and so to do that we'd like to actually
find tree structures like this
dependency structure i show here um
within bird representations
um so this
dependency representation again is
showing syntactic dependency the chef
who ran to the store was out of food so
this represents that who ran to the food
is modifying chef and in particular it
represents as chef as a direct dependent
was even though it's much further away
from was than the store
this seems kind of difficult to
reconcile
vectors above words
with a syntactic tree structure
but a way that we can hope to do so is
using the idea of a distance metric
so we can place a distance metric on
trees
so an undirected tree has a distance
metric
which is the just the length of the path
between tree nodes so the distance
between store and was is one two three
four whereas the distance between chef
and was is just one
and well we have a very obvious form of
a distance metric in vector spaces so
let's see if we can reconcile these
so
with these
um vector representations we're going to
look um at the
well strictly actually the square of the
distances between these vectors there's
technical reason for that that i won't
actually discuss here so here's the
sentence embedded by the neural network
and well it seems unreasonable to just
simply use the whole of those vector
representations because most of those
vectors aren't representing syntactic
structure they also have to be
representing the meaning of words
and the context in which they appear
that's a lot of it is discourse
structure so maybe just like the linear
projections in a transformer what we
should do is find a linear
transformation of these representations
which is just capturing syntactic
structure
so our goal will be to
make a linear projection linear
transformation projection of
these word vectors that gives us just
their syntax based representation and to
hope that in that subspace
distance in that subspace will
correspond to tree distance
and our goal will be to learn a single
linear transformation b
which makes that as true as possible
and so if we can do that
then we can recover syntax trees from
our bert representation simply by
projecting to that subspace and then
finding the minimum spanning tree
between the words in that subspace that
will be the syntactic structure of the
sentence
so to operationalize that we've trained
a burt model completely independently of
any knowledge of syntax just from
predicting words but then we make use of
a tree bank simply to try and find a b
matrix one b matrix used everywhere that
will do this projection onto the
syntactic subspace
and it turns out that if we do that we
can actually do it very well
so for simpler models such as word
embedding or older generation
recurrent neural networks they don't
actually learn that much syntax in
particular there's a baseline for
syntactic structure in english that
english has strongly write with
branching syntactic structure so if you
just attach each word to the previous
word you get about 49
and these models don't do much better
than that but the modern large language
pre-trained language models do much much
better so even an elmo model does pretty
well and if you go up to
a bert model you're actually doing a
pretty good job at recovering the
syntactic structure of sentences so
here's one example where the black is
showing a human annotated parse tree and
the teal below is showing the recovered
minimum spanning tree and if you look um
it's recovered almost perfectly there's
a little bit of error over here to the
right
um this doesn't only work for english in
fact people have trained
um large pre-trained language models
multilingually so you have multilingual
bird and so what we can do is look at
its representations for different
languages and so these models are again
are trained with an on-word prediction
they get no supervision at all about
grammatical relation labels yet what we
do
when we
make this syntactic projection is we
find that we have clear grammatical
relation clusters and indeed they extend
across languages so that we have
clustered together
french subjects and english
french
subjects
english determiners
french and english objects and so we
actually seem to be finding a universal
grammatical relation vocabulary heading
across languages
and so that's really interesting
um
prior to the rise of chomsky in
linguistics the dominant school in the
us was american structuralism um and in
the later period of american
structuralism when there were um
linguists like yusun zeli harris that's
period was sometimes referred to as
distributionalism a school of thought
that was rather distinct from european
structuralism and these american
structuralists essentially believed in
there being a language discovery
procedure that you could come up with
the discovery procedure for grammars now
in truth that they had almost no idea of
how to do this this was
essentially before any methods were
developed corresponding to modern
machine learning about as far as they
got with some ideas as to how to work
out phonemes
from different allophonic
representations of sounds
but nevertheless the idea was there and
there was an idea that then chomsky
rejected he didn't believe that it was
possible to have a mechanical discovery
procedure
for the grammar of the human language
indeed this was part of his argument
that actually the structure of human
languages has to be innate within human
brains but interestingly it seems that
with these modern large transformer
language models we've actually
made a mechanical discovery procedure
for human language syntax and that's
actually quite remarkable
okay let me move on now to mention one
other piece of work that i've been
involved in particularly with my student
um kevin clark and this is an
alternative approach to learning
large transformer language models that
is more efficient
and i've contextualized this by looking
at results on the glue benchmark which
is a benchmark for natural language
understanding tasks it has a variety of
different tasks in it but the commonest
kind of task is natural language
inference tasks and in these tasks
you're given two pieces of text a
premise piece of text and particular
hypothesis so a premise maybe of hills
and mountains are especially sanctified
in jainism and then a hypothesis jainism
hates nature and you have to say whether
the hypothesis is supported by the text
contradicts the text or they don't have
any particular relation so in this
example the hypothesis is contradicted
by the text
so for this task
people
started exploring with simpler neural
network models getting about 67
but then from 2017 forward for the last
four years um performance on this task
has zoomed as people built
initial models like elmo gpt and bert
base and then is zoomed even more as
people have built larger
pre-trained
transformer language models like excel
net roberta and albert indeed again at
this point
the best models are performing better
than human mechanical
turk workers on these tasks so that
looks like amazing performance over four
years a three times error reduction
however if we change the x-axis instead
to the compute required things don't
look quite so rosy um so simple neural
models in retrospect used almost no
compute elmo was built to be actually
quite computer fisher and whereas once
we started
out into the bert family either the bert
base or the larger bird size we were
using massively more compute so burt
large uses 60 times more compute than
elmo how much compute is that
well
but base is using
6 times 10 to the 19 flops and but large
is then using
2 times 10 to the 20 flops
but in retrospect that was only the
start because people then went on from
there and built models like excel net
and roberta and while roberta is using
16 times more compute than burt large
but why stop there
moving on to more recent models again
like albert and the now very popular t5
it's using about 10 times more compute
than roberta um so
if you the kind of person that knows
your
si abbreviations we're now up to 30
zetta flops
3 times 10 to the 22 flops
so what we are actually observing is
each successive model is using
exponentially more compute than the last
model and we're starting to pay an
extremely high price in the amount of
compute needed to make what are
increasingly minor
benefits in terms of performance and so
the question is can we do any better
than that
my colleague andrew ing likes the slogan
ai is the new electricity but after
examining these graphs maybe we should
go with a different slogan electricity
is the new ai
so i want to introduce a different idea
that
kevin developed that has a bit of
promise in these regards so up until now
there have been two main ways of doing
language model pre-training there's
simply at each point predicting the next
word so from the artist sold you
predicted the from the art of soul that
you predicted painting classic language
models and things like the gpt series
um then there was the idea of burt of
mass language model training where you
used a two-sided context and so these
actually worked better but they had a
cost which was in practice you mask only
about 15 of the words so one word and
seven and you're effectively only
learning for the words that you've
masked so you're only learning from a
seventh of the data
um so what kevin's idea was that we
could improve on this by coming up with
a different pre-training task of replace
token detection so we're going to
replace
some words let's say again 15 of the
words
though you can do more by words similar
in meaning and then what our job is
going to be is to predict which words
have been replaced so we're just then
predicting original or replaced and so
this gives us two wins firstly we're
learning from every word rather than
only
one seventh of the words and secondly
rather than having a huge soft max over
the entire vocabulary at the top here
which is itself very expensive to
compute we're only doing binary
classification
so formally how you do this is you do
have to generate these plausible
alternatives and we actually do that
with a small generator language model
which can itself be a small mass
language model and interestingly it
actually works better for this model to
be small so it's not too good and that's
also then good for being energy
efficient
so we're then going to simultaneously
train these two models so the generator
is trained with standard mass language
model loss and the discriminator is
trained by binary classification
and then once we've done the training of
the discriminator we just throw away the
generator and use the representations
and the discriminator that we call
electra so this picture makes it look
rather like a gan
model but it's unlike again because the
generator is being trained by standard
mle rather than adversarially
um but using this model we do actually
achieve
what we'd like so the only real progress
in large language model
models is if you can drive things up to
the top left corner so that you're able
to get better performance while using
less energy to do so
how well does that work well here are a
couple of more specific statistics so
for the squad quest question answering
task we can build a model which takes
the same number of flops to train as
burt large model and the electra model
with the same amount of compute can do
much better on
f1 score it can get the same kind of f1
score of much bigger
models like xlnet that take five times
as much
training flops
going in the other direction we can look
at very small models so you can build a
little electra model that you can train
180 times as fast as a bert based model
and it still performs decently well on
tasks like glue and squad question
answering so that gets you down to a
model that you can train in one day on
one v100 nvidia gpu i this is the kind
of
model technology that makes it very
feasible
for students at universities to
experiment with training these kinds of
models
okay so
this replace token detection is an
effective new pre-training task which is
achieving our goal of improving the
quality efficiency curve and is a great
model for be using for lightweight
experimentation
that gets me through the two main pieces
of work i talked about for the last
bit of time i want to talk for a minute
about where things are heading next and
what we're doing at stanford
going beyond
the bert or electra models we're now in
a world of massively larger models again
most notably the gpt-3 model from open
ai
and the people at openai showed the
remarkable result that once you build
models they're about two orders of
magnitude bigger than a model like burt
it then has these amazing capabilities
where you can get it simply by means of
prompting by giving it some context to
do all sorts of natural language tasks
in quite surprising ways despite the
fact that it was only trained on the
pre-training task of next word
prediction so you can write
dear richard dawkins
email note saying can you explain some
concept and it will
um you can ask it to describe concepts
or how a person would describe something
and it will
you can ask it
to translate
pieces of legalese into plain english
and it will
you can
this one's even more remarkable
you can ask it
to
write some javascript for you to produce
something like a button that looks like
a watermelon and it will
so this
seems like we've into a new world where
we've generated a model where you can
just ask it to do things in
natural language and it will
and so we're seeing this as the
beginning of a new era where we've had
yet another phase change into just a
much more powerful form of model and so
at stanford we've started using the term
foundation models to describe these
really huge
pre-trained models so we have
self-supervised models that be been
pre-trained on a huge amount of data
that can be easily adapted to do a very
wide range of different tasks
by either just prompting or a minor
amount of fine-tuning
now why do we choose the name foundation
models well at this point this isn't
just a story about language models
anymore what we're seeing happening
right at the moment is the technology of
transformer models is being very
productively deployed in all sorts of
other places so people have started
building vision transformers and getting
exciting new vision results from them
people are using transformer models
in bioinformatics context such as
protein structure prediction and again
huge pre-trained models
giving you enormously powerful
performance whereas
older
models
trained on just supervised data sets of
the kind that people are using three or
four years ago just aren't promising for
the same kind of complex
protein structure prediction problems
people are building multilingual models
so that you have models that go between
human language and vision or
generation of graphics so um here open
ai's dali model you can ask for
something like an illustration of a baby
hedgehog in a christmas sweater walking
a dog and most of the time that's what
it will produce for you with a few
little deviations as you can see
you can get these models to produce code
for you
and less explored but it seems only a
matter of time until they'll be
increasing use of these models in video
and robotics applications as well and so
these kind of
huge
self-supervised pre-trained models seem
that they will be giving a new general
infrastructure base
for building large ai systems and we're
calling that foundation models
and in particular these foundation
models are showing qualitatively
different behavior so although we do
self-supervised learning for a very
simple prediction task such as next word
prediction when we build huge neural
networks and train these neural networks
on enormous scales of data orders of
magnitudes that were used for something
like bert
or t5 that we find the emergence of
fundamentally different capabilities so
you can just prompt this model and ask
it to do all sorts of things so you can
say find a word that rhymes like duck
and luck
how about for lunch and it will
correctly say munch even though it
doesn't seem like it was trained to know
about something like rhyming whatsoever
and it's also changing completely the
way people are going to go about
doing natural language processing and
increasingly other tasks like vision and
robotics
until a few years ago people worked on a
particular problem so someone might be
working on machine translation or
working on co-reference resolution or
working on question answering and quite
commonly a phd student might choose one
of these and work on it for their entire
phd
but that's been completely changed
now we are making use of large
pre-trained models and what we find is
one large pre-trained model such as a t5
model can be used for all of these tasks
and systems built using that t5 model
perform much better for each individual
task than anything that people have
managed to build as standalone models
for question answering or co-reference
resolution
so it's in this
sense that these new models act as a
foundation for whole fields
and they have wonderful breadth but also
they potentially have worries because of
their homogenization
you are using one model for everything
and indeed despite their great success
there are still lots of concerns that
people rightly should have about
foundation models the models are still
brittle they frequently seem to lack
common sense or even internal
consistency in what they produce
the models are trained on large amounts
of data scoop from the real world
and partly because of that and partly
because of the nature of these models
they can easily generate biased or
offensive or just non-factual content
they can also be used at scale to
deliberately astroturf disinformation
the sheer size of these models also
creates
barriers and worries they require large
amounts of resources and many of these
models aren't as open to researchers
across the community as previous
generations of machine learning models
and as a response to that at stanford we
thought it's important to develop and
investigate these models more thoroughly
in an open academic context and so we've
started work in producing infrastructure
so that we can make at least medium
scale foundation model training
accessible and reliable with tools that
lots of researchers can use and you can
check out our start on that in the
mistral code base
which is
stable code for tr for training large
language models that fits inside um the
hugging face transformers framework we
think it's important to get lots more
people involved in
studying these foundation models not
only computer scientists and not only
people and who work at a handful of huge
technology companies
but also looking at what people who are
lawyers economists ethicists
medical sciences lots and lots of people
have things to contribute in
exploring the range of impacts and the
range of uses of foundation models
and we're wanting to explore
many aspects of these models we just
recently
released the first hefty report on
foundation models that you can find on
archive and we're increasing education
with new courses being taught on
foundation models this year
there is still a huge amount to explore
as to how to do better data governance
how to guide policies around the use of
these models how to better make these
models available to a broader community
of people while not incurring great
risks
but you know i think it is important to
realize that these foundation models
really are opening uh phase change in
the way that we're building uh models
for machine learning and artificial
intelligence and it's still day one in
the exploration of these models and that
there's a huge amount of work that many
in the community can and should be doing
to help shape how these models are
explored and the way that they end up
okay thank you for that talk um here's
a few of the relevant papers that i've
been mentioning in the talk and it's
been great getting to
present this at the amazon machine
learning conference thank you